The right rises,
the hard revolting rate rises.
It feeds off immigration,
but it rises when those decent
politicians on the right give it room to
rise and doesn't fight it.
I watched Marine Le Pen rise and it was
when the conventional parties in France
bent towards her and the advent of Ukip
and its rise is because the conservative
party did the same thing and mark and
Angela Merkel is an example of what you
can do to lead a nation to another
destination.
Churchill called us the Mongrel nation
and so we are,
we are the product of succeeding waves
of immigration into this country and it
makes us what we are and this is the
Mongrel city and it is the most
successful global city in the world
because of that place,
a barrier up to it as the gentleman over
here once and you remove that.
I disagreed with the idea that it's only
Muslims who are responsible for
overturning our values.
You've always been able to find
gentleman over there was right young men
who will see,
who will think it is part of a noble
calls to kill innocent people.
That was the anarchist at the turn of
the 19th century.
It was the bottom line,
half guard gang.
It was the road facsia.
I don't have to go to Baghdad to hear a
preacher preaching death row.
Put it.
I can go to Belfast.
These have always been there,
and it is wrong of Malcolm Rifkind to
ascribe this simply to Muslims.
These are people who wish to overturn
the values,
who happened to be Muslims,
but we've had plenty of Christians
seeking to do it.
Look,
we haven't got all the answers.
This is one of the really great
conundrums,
challenges,
moral and practical to confront us.
I know some of the things we ought to be
doing or not doing,
but I haven't got a solution to all of
these.
We're going to have to think,
but I'll tell you one thing.
If you do not do this on the basis of
your humanity,
then you will be left with only one way
to do it.
Moats and walls and barbed wire,
and then you lose your humanity and
you'll create another reason for even
more walls.
[inaudible].